and the white house has found a new
strategy to shield biden from tough
questions a staffer dressed up as the
easter bunny appears to interrupt the
president and usher him away while he
was talking about afghanistan
all right greg who was in that easter
bunny i don't know but finally he found
uh some hair he didn't want to sniff
oh that's fair
oh he's hugging him waiting he's hugging
him you didn't see the whole you don't
know who that is that might be kamala
yeah well you know that's the only way
you can get close to joe nice i haven't
seen you in rice but but it's like that
his slogan i mean that should be his
campaign campaign slogan joe biden not
much he can do because then it's like
you know it's like because that's kind
of where we are right now we do know
that he's not running this this show who
do you think is running the show i don't
know but i you know i i can't believe
it's him because he seems so out of it
all the time i don't have i don't think
he makes decisions i think he gets up he
sits down he enjoys wearing the jacket
in the sun